Mike when it comes to deciding what film
project to work on next do you tend to
choose things that are familiar to you
or things that slightly scare you well a
little bit of both I think you know I've
had friends approach me with their
projects that need help and so it's more
like I care about the people involved
and and I know I know what I have access
to and I can kind of gather the
resources together to make something
happen you know different sci-fi
projects or different documentary
projects and I think you know every
project scares you really I mean when
you're saying oh man you know we're
going to pull together this team and do
the impossible everything every project
is always a little bit like who knows
we're going to try and that's and that's
what you do and you kind of put together
the best people you can and you hope
nothing goes wrong and I've had things
go wrong you know I've had lens sets go
down on set and we've had to get a full
new you know prime set so it's like you
just got to keep going with it and and
push them so how important do you think
it is for a filmmaker to be willing to
risk I suppose they only want to do
stuff that feels safe only with people
that they know or subject matters that
they're really well versed in I mean
high in terms of you know that comfort
zone yeah I'll get into how important do
you think it is for people to really try
to break out of that and not stay with
stuff that they know so much about that
they're like okay I got this I think you
know if you're interested in growing
you're not going to grow by doing the
same thing over and over again although
some people get better and better doing
the same thing over and over again and
so you kind of have to think well are
you going to become a pro at comedies
and only do comedies and you got to
focus on your comedy I mean imagine if
someone didn't practice comedy they
would just not be as
it's like soccer or any kind of sport if
the more you practice the better get at
it so that's kind of where I see you
know different categories of filmmaking
like you know if you're if you want to
work with a team of two and do that over
and over again you'll probably be a
really good team of two but when you get
on set with 30 people wanting to know
what's up you're not going to know what
to do so yeah you got to push push into
new things you know hire 15 people have
a bunch of PAS have a set you know work
with 10 actors these things are going to
like you know wow you know it's going to
be way different than working with the
team of tuning though can you think of a
project that would scare you I mean just
for me as an outsider you've got these
cool photos you meet all these awesome
people it seems like you have these
lasting relationships so what if you
were do something totally different that
wasn't about your connections with these
people how would you approach that like
maybe a narrative where it's it's a
zombie whatever I mean is there
something that I'm putting words in your
mouth oh yeah there's something that
scares you that you've yet to try yeah I
I am well I mean a Metallica documentary
yeah I don't know something where you're
you know you're gonna need a Moscow
would scare me is if I just wasn't into
the script you know if I wasn't feeling
it then it would scare me most the time
like I'm participating and I'm involved
and I'm producing or whatever because
I'm feeling it because the scripts
amazing because the other people
involved are amazing because you know
someone's on set that I really admire
and I admire their acting and and and
you know those end up like working out I
think it'd be scary if I was working on
something I didn't believe in you know I
didn't feel good about so you know and
I've read a bunch of scripts and there's
definitely script sorta like really kind
of weird and I'm you know I'm just not
into it so I wouldn't I wouldn't be
involved but
even if the pay was good well I mean
I've definitely helped out on set on
different things I've been a PA I was a
PA on die hard for and it was actually
really frustrating because my job was to
guard a street with a walkie-talkie and
make sure there was no pedestrians and I
felt like I wasn't doing enough I felt
like I wasn't useful enough even though
I got paid to be on set that day I felt
like how more can I help what more can I
be doing can I be you know so it was
frustrating to be kind of like in a
position where I couldn't decide to do
more interesting Wow okay so it sounds
like nothing scares you as long as your
hearts in it but that maybe that's the
scary part is doing stuff that you're
just kind of like phoning it in yes p
and and if you had to do that for
whatever reason whether to keep a
promise to somebody or for the money how
would you do that every day and still
show up because I think that's a tough
thing for a lot of people to do yeah you
know you know people have different ways
of living life i think you know if every
day you're doing something that's
inspiring that you're passionate about
well then every day is awesome and you
can live life like fully alive i think
if you're doing something you're not
passionate about for too many days it's
it's a drain and it becomes it becomes
depressing
you